-Cailee, welcome to the show.
I'm so excited that you're here.
Not only because
I loved your performance,
but this is your first
talk-show appearance.
-It's my first one.
-Ever.
I'm so happy
to be your first talk-show host.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
I want to know all about you.
We all do.
We'll talk about "Priscilla"
and what a great job.
But where are you from?
Where is this --
Where does it all start?
-I was born in Tennessee
and I was raised
in Southern Missouri.
-Yeah.
-Sheryl's actually
from Southern Missouri, too,
so shout-out
to the Missouri girls tonight.
-Yeah, doing pretty well.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Were you musical growing up?
-Yeah, I sort of did
a bunch of different things.
I did, like, musical theater
and I was in a kids cover band.
-Ooh! Tell me about that.
-Yeah. Well, we were
called Energy, but capital NRG,
which is really hardcore.
-Really cool. Yeah, NRG.
-NRG. Do you get it?
I don't know if you do,
-No, but now I do, yeah.
Do you guys get it?
NRG, Energy?
Where would you play?
-We'd do, like, all --
We'd do, you know,
Halloween parties,
birthday parties,
some fall festivals, you know.
-You could book NRG,
and they would come
and they would just do
all the hits.
-All the hits.
We did Joan Jett,
Pat Benatar, Pink Floyd,
you know, depending on what
the mood was the night --
-How cool were these kids
you were playing for?
I mean, this is --
-Yeah, we were pretty --
-Pink Floyd?
-Yeah. Yeah, we were cool kids.
Yeah, I did -- Actually, like,
I played at a fall festival,
and that's where I got
my sort of ticket to L.A.
It was like this guy
came up to me, and he was like,
"I've got a Myspace band,
and I know someone who knows
someone who's a manager in L.A."
I'm like, "Great!
-"I have a Myspace band"?
-Yeah. I'm like,
"Let's pack the bag."
-And you were like,
"This is my big break, Mom."
-Yeah. And we did. We packed
the bags, and my mom --
-You believed this man.
-I mean, yeah.
That was my only way in.
-This man got you
where you are today.
-Yeah.
-No way.
-I know.
-From his Myspace band
that he thought that -- Wow!
-He really helped me out.
So, we went on the journey.
It was like a 25-hour
cross-country drive.
And it was a wild, wild ride.
-Did you plan on doing music in
L.A. or acting or both?
-Just anything.
I was like, "I'm your girl."
-Yeah. "I can do it.
I can do it all." Yeah.
And then you end up getting --
you get "Priscilla."
-Yeah, so crazy.
I mean, Sofia Coppola
was my dream director.
-She's the coolest.
-Yeah.
-I would get nervous
around just even
hanging out with her,
seeing Sofia Coppola.
-Oh, gosh,
she's so chic and chill.
And she just --
She's just so -- She's so fun.
-She's we kind of --
In your head, you go,
"Oh, she's kind of like
a perfect --
just cool and does everything."
I go, "What would
surprise me about Sofia?"
-Yeah. Yeah.
-And you brought me a photo.
-This surprised me, as well.
-Yeah. She plays pickleball.
-In between -- This was in prep.
She painted a pickleball court.
Also, we had 30 days
to shoot this movie,
which is not a lot of time,
but we still found time
to play pickleball.
We ended up --
-There's you and Jacob.
-This is a tournament.
It ended up turning into
a whole tournament,
which she, of course, won.
You know, we worked hard
and we played hard.
That's that's how she does it.
-Exactly.
-The Sofia Coppola way.
-She's the coolest.
-She is the coolest.
-And you got to go
to Venice Film Festival.
-Yeah, yeah. We were
lucky enough to go to Venice.
-And you got
a crazy standing ovation.
Everyone loved your performance.
But here's what I want to hear.
You go in,
you sit down in your seat,
and who sits next to you?
-Yeah, so, it's my first time
at the Venice Film Festival,
and it's this --
It's like what you think of
in your dreams.
You know,
it's a massive festival.
-Red carpet, paparazzi.
-Yeah, it's unbelievable.
And I hadn't seen the film yet,
because I was just so nervous
to watch myself on-screen
for two hours in every frame.
Like, I don't know anyone
who wants to do that.
-I do.
-Oh, you do?
-Yeah. You're really good.
You're really good.
Yeah, you're very good.
-So, yeah, we got there,
and I --
The whole plan was that
they were going to sneak me out
during the show and I was going
to come back for the ending.
And then I turned to Sofia
at the last minute.
I'm like, "I don't know.
What do you think I should do?"
And she's like,
"This is a really special night.
I think you should
watch the movie."
I'm like, "Okay, yeah, great.
I'm not going to say
no to Sofia."
And then I sit down,
and Priscilla Presley --
They sat me right next
to Priscilla Presley.
So I'm watching --
-That's the best.
That's exactly what you want.
-Most out-of-body experience
of my life.
-Well, also, what do you do?
Do you watch your performance
or do you watch
Priscilla's reaction
to your, like, performance?
"I'm playing you."
-Jacob was right in between us.
So I would go,
"Jacob, how's it looking?"
-Like, "Dude,
make a break for it.
She does not like it."
Yeah.
But she loved it.
-Yeah, it's the first time
she turned to me,
and she said that she liked
the performance
and she got to watch her life
through the movie,
which is, like,
the best review you can --
-Did you get to interview her
before you did --
-Yeah, yeah, I got to spend
some time with her,
which was wild, you know,
growing up an Elvis fan.
You know, we did road trips to
Graceland with the family.
-It must be surreal.
-So surreal.
You know, I had all
these questions planned out,
getting ready to meet her,
but then Priscilla Presley
walks in through the doors,
and everything goes out
of your head.
I couldn't get words out
of my mouth.
-Yeah, you're like, "W-W-W-What
is rock 'n' roll?"
"What? What is rock 'n' roll?"
-Like, staring at the table,
and she, like, sat down
and she's like, "So, do you want
to ask me any questions?"
I was like, "Uh, yeah, right."
-"We should do that, yeah."
-"We should do that.
That's a great idea."
-But did she say, like,
any, like --
And you don't have to
say it here,
but, like, any, like,
moments that you go like,
"Wow, that's kind of an intimate
moment between you and Elvis."
-Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, her eyes would,
like, light up.
Like, she went back
to those moments.
I remember one she told me,
which was so touching.
She -- When she first went to
the party
to meet Elvis
for the first night,
she was so hungry
because she was --
She just couldn't eat all day.
She was so nervous
to go to the party.
And then she went,
she saw him, and he was, like,
making her a sandwich.
And he's like,
"Do you want a sandwich?"
And she was like,
"I can't eat a sandwich
in front of Elvis Presley."
She's like, "There's no way."
-He made her a sandwich?
-Yeah.
-That's fantastic.
I love stories like that.
-I know.
-That's so wild.
You're great in this movie.
-Thanks for saying that.
-Congratulations.
No, it's awesome.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Cailee Spaeny
in "Priscilla."
Take a look.
-What do you think? You like it?
-I love it.
I can't believe you did this.
[ Laughs ]
-Alright, it's time to go.
Scilla's graduating.
-Can I ask you something?
I was wondering if maybe you
could wait outside the ceremony,
'cause I'm afraid you being
there might take away
the attention
from the graduates.
-Well, yeah, I-I guess
I hadn't -- I hadn't
thought of it like that.
I-I won't come in.
I'll, uh -- I'll wait for you
outside in the car.
In a way,
it'll kind of be like I'm there.
-Thank you.
-Come on.
Cailee Spaeny, everyone!
"Priscilla" is in theaters
nationwide tomorrow.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around.
Come back, please.
-Okay.